[Musique]
atelier de découpage de coloriage avec
des enfants atelier couture pour les
parents et les adultes bienvenue au
Secours Catholique de brapanon cette
section fonctionne avec 10 bénévoles qui
mettent en place toutes ces activités
plusieurs fois par semaine tout ce petit
monde se retrouve pour échanger un
savoir-faire mais également pour
partager les soucis du quotidien il faut
dire que nos après-midis
se tourne un petit peu autour de la
couture autour d'un échange j'allais
dire échange de parole autour d'un café
ou d'un thé qu'on partage et un atelier
cuisine aussi qu'on met en place cette
année mais c'est vraiment pour
confectionner des petites choses et pour
que chacun puisse apporter son petit
savoir et partager avec les autres nous
ici on fonctionne et notre mot d'ordre
c'est le partage c'est la fraternité
c'est la
solidarité ce qu'on veut c'est changer
le regard qu'on peut avoir sur son
voisin quoi le Secours Catholique créé
pour venir en aide au plus démunis
permet aux femmes de la commune de
brapanon de sortir de leur isolement ici
on récupère les be jeans pour en faire
des sacs pour ces enfants qui sont en
vacances mais qui fautent de moyens
resteront à la maison deux fois par
semaine cet atelier avec les bénévoles
du Secours Catholique les activités se
font plutôt l'après-midi pour les adult
euh il y a des temps d'activité manuell
on a des temps de partage on a des temps
de sorties aussi qui sont mise mise en
place et pendant les semaines de
vacances on essaie donc d'habitude on
fait beaucoup plus les journées beaucoup
plus longues mais là cette année pour
ces vacances on fait un accueil
d'enfants de 6 à 12 ans de fois par
semaine en 2016 le Secours Catholique
fête son 70e anniversaire au niveau
national et ses 60 ans sur l'île de la R
à cette occasion le département a été
partenaire de l'association en
accueillant les marches fraternelles au
jardin de l'État ainsi qu'une exposition
dans les salons de la ville c'est une
association qui a été créée après la
guerre pour répondre au besoins de la
population en matière de
d'accompagnement des personnes en
situation de de pauvreté de précarité
l'idée c'est vraiment de se retrouver de
se réunir pour monter ensemble des
projet qui puisse répondre au maximum
aux besoins réels de des personnes et ce
soit comme je disais tout à l'heure
vraiment elle qui soit actrice de leur
projet et donc ça peut être se retrouver
autour d'un d'un café d'un thé et puis
de bah de parler ensemble de ce qu'on a
envie de faire outre l'accueil et
l'écoute de milieux de personnes le
Secours catholique veut éduquer les
jeunes à la tolérance parmi les exemple
de projets imaginés par les jeunes
réunionnés un échange avec des jeunes
maorés pour faire tomber les préjugés en
plus de vouloir améliorer le monde
d'aujourd'hui le Secours Catholique
souhaite également changer le monde de
demain en faisant de chaque humain un
citoyen
[Musique]